des panaches de fumée jalonnent la route
qui mène à licite chance qu
ici l'artillerie russe frappe sans
relâche
dans cette ville du dombass quasiment
coupée du monde
quelques rares habitants ont décidé de
rester
ce soir je vais dormir dans ma cave j'ai
peur mon quartier n'a pas été trop
bombarder mais ici en centre ville c'est
bien pire on essaie de continuer à vivre
manager bernad agite une vie sans eau
potable
ni électricité
l'aide humanitaire est devenue le seul
recours
je suis venu chercher de l'eau pour
pouvoir me laver c'est de l'eau non
potable mais dieu merci au monde à ça et
pour l'eau potable en fait comment on se
sert des puits
à l'ouest la ville voisine de
severodonezk ce qui est presque
totalement encerclée par l'armée russe
les forces du craignent elles font tout
pour défendre ce verrou stratégique
kelly si tu chantes ce qui est pris
entre deux feux
sur la ligne de front ça tire dans tous
les sens ou dessus de nos têtes on ne
peut rien faire d'autre que s'en
remettre à dieu
ici dit walid othmani tout haut niveau
je ne dirai
mihailo accepte de nous emmener chez lui
il est resté au chevet de sa mère malade
incapable de se déplacer
je ne peux aller nulle part
comment pourrait repartir alors qu'elle
est dans cet état c'est horrible ce
conte désolé de pleurer je suis triste
pour moi même
les troupes russes sont à trois
kilomètres à peine si elles parviennent
à percer les défenses ukrainienne au sol
licite chance qui deviendra un champ de
bataille